tensorflow lite allows you to do machine
learning on small devices
bhavish is an experienced instructor and
he will teach you all about tensorflow
lite in this course hello everyone
in this tutorial you would learn the
basics of tensorflow lite
and how tensorflow lite can help you
create really efficient models that you
can deploy on edge devices
so without wasting any further time
let's kick start the tutorial
let us kick start today's discussion
about tflight with a small story
i have a friend whose name is john
john really likes travelling to
different places
one of his favorite applications is
google lens
whenever he visits a new country
he removes his cell phone
takes a photograph of the monument that
he is in front of
and google essentially tells him which
monument it is
so now just by the sheer fascination of
the tool
jon goes forward and creates his own
neural network for detecting landmarks
he goes through a rigorous process of
collecting data labeling data cleaning
data and finally he creates a machine
learning model that can tell jon which
monument it is
so everything looks good he is able to
reach a very high accuracy score as well
now the only challenge that he has is
where should he deploy the model that
he's created
so technically he has two options
the option that he explores first is
cloud computing
he takes his trained model and he
deploys it on cloud
he exposes the api that he has created
and essentially he creates an android
application that kind of queries the api
and fetches the result once he's kind of
passed in an image
now one of the major challenges that he
saw when he created the solution is the
network latency
so the images that are captured
generally by cell phones today range
anywhere between 3 to 10 mb
so transporting such huge files take up
a lot of time in the entire process of
making a prediction
the second piece that adds complexity to
the entire solution is the cost the
neural network that john has created
requires two resources
a storage resource wherein he can save
the model weights
and a compute resource for making an
inference
the overall project becomes a costly
affair for john
what does he do next
he creates an android application and he
finds a way to make an inference on
android using this huge model that he's
created
so john now faces a new issue
the issue is the model is really huge
and the cell phone is not very capable
enough of storing and processing such a
big model
so now john is really confused he's
tried out different techniques to make
this work but nothing is solving his
issue
well it is here that tf light comes into
picture
before we jump and discuss about df
light
i wanted to throw some light in terms of
what edge devices are
so edge devices are your normal cell
phones that you use
so if you're planning to create some
amazing tensorflow based applications
then essentially one of the main
platforms that you can utilize is your
cell phones
be it your android cell phone or an ios
powered cell phone anything works
the other pieces of hardware devices
that you can classify into edge devices
are microcontrollers
so there are some amazing applications
that have been built using very small
compute power
and all of it is thanks to
microcontrollers
given how recently the variable devices
that you wear essentially have increased
their computation power by using a more
faster cpu you can also put your
variable devices such as your smart
watches into the edge computing bracket
now let me go forward and give you a
formal definition of edge computing
so edge computing is basically the
practice of moving compute and storage
resources closer to the location at
which it is needed so that is where your
edge devices would come into picture
now if you recollect john had two
options to deploy the model
the first option was to deploy the model
on cloud
now many of you would have the
impression that a machine learning model
running on the server using a large gpu
is much more better as compared to
running it on the device itself
well the truth is edge devices have
become an important platform for machine
learning
why is it gaining so much of popularity
that you essentially have to run your
entire machine learning models on the
edge devices
well let me share details one at a time
the first and foremost reason why edge
computing as a whole is gaining
popularity is because of latency
the use cases that require real-time
speed definitely require models to run
on the device
for example you might be able to reduce
the inference latency of resnet 50 from
30 milliseconds to 20 milliseconds
but the network latency can go up to
seconds
so essentially it also depends on where
your model is deployed where are you
querying the api from
so if you take into account all of these
factors then essentially deploying a
model on server would not be the best
possible situation when you want
inferences in near real time or exactly
real time as well
the second reason why creating machine
learning models on edge devices is
important is because of network
connectivity
so if you go back to our earlier example
wherein john wanted to create his own
version of google lens for detecting
landmarks
if he happens to visit a country where
there is little to no connectivity it is
here that creating a model that sits on
the device would be much more better as
compared to deploying it on server
because there is this additional
dependency on the network that comes
into picture
the third reason why it's very important
for you to create machine learning
models that run on edge devices
is user privacy
putting your machine learning models on
the edge devices
is also appealing when you are handling
sensitive user data
machine learning on the cloud means that
your systems might have to send user
data over networks
making it susceptible to being
intercepted
cloud computing also means that storing
data of many users in the same place or
location which means a data breach can
affect many people at once
so it becomes really important to create
machine learning models that can run on
edge devices which can preserve the user
privacy data
let me now go forward and show you some
examples of on-device machine learning
use cases
the first one that i am showing you
right now is the feature to try out
various cosmetics using ar on youtube
the entire computation piece that you
are seeing here is essentially happening
on the device itself
now the second example that i want to
show you is something that you might be
already aware of which is google
translate
google translate has a feature that
allows you to capture text with your
phone camera
and translate them in real time without
any internet connection
all of this is essentially possible
using edge computing and more
specifically tf light
now that you've seen the amazing two
applications that you can create at your
end as well
you might be wondering
the second alternative that john had
taken initially that is to create an
entire huge tensorflow model and then
run inferences from the device why did
that fail
well to answer that question here are
some of the challenges that you might
face when you create keras or tensorflow
models and deploy them directly onto
edge devices
edge devices not only restricted to
mobile phones but your microcontrollers
as well have limited compute power
limited memory
battery consumption is also a factor
that you have to account for as well as
the application size
if i consider a simple microcontroller
as well the processing power isn't so
much that you can essentially run
inferences on a 3 or 4 gb model
if you consider the storage capacity of
majority of the edge devices as well
then ideally you wouldn't have a lot of
storage that you can utilize for just
one model
so these are the challenges that jon
faced when he took the second approach
as well
so what is the solution well the
solution is tensorflow lite
tensorflow lite is a production ready
cross platform framework for deploying
machine learning models on mobile
devices and embedded systems
tensorflow lite at this point of time
supports android
ios
and any iot device that can run linux so
essentially if you have
any of these hardware devices handy with
you then you can quickly create a
tensorflow model convert it to an
equivalent pflight model and start using
the amazing tflight model
now you might wonder what exactly is the
workflow to create a ta flight model
well let's look at that as well
so the workflow is fairly simple you
start by creating a tensorflow slash
keras model
so in the entire process you would have
to collect data you would have to clean
data pre-process data then create models
iterate over multiple models and based
on the matrix that you're chasing if you
are chasing for a higher accuracy score
then you would choose a model that would
give you the best possible accuracy
and that's about it you have your
tensorflow model ready
now from that tensorflow model you
convert it to a tensorflow lite model so
there is a format change that happens
i'll talk more about it as we go along
once you've converted your model from
tensorflow to tensorflow lite then you
go forward and deploy the entire tflight
model and run your inferences on the
edge device when i mean inferences i
mean predictions okay
let me now explain this using a block
diagram
so this essentially is the workflow that
i've just mentioned you start off with
your high level keras apis
create a model
once you have the model ready then you
can essentially use a ta flight
converter
and the converter basically takes your
save tensorflow format file
and converts into a flat buffer file
i'll give you an idea in terms of what i
mean by flat buffer file so let's move
forward
so tensorflow lite represents your model
in a flat buffer format
now flat buffer format is an efficient
cross platform serialization library for
c plus plus c sharp go java kotlin
javascript python and so on and so forth
it was originally created at google for
game development and other performance
critical applications
but slowly google realized that you can
use the flat buffer format in deploying
models on edge devices
now you might have an obvious question
why not use our old tried and tested
protocol buffers
and why shift to something that is as
new as flat buffers
protocol buffers just to give you
context all your kiras models that you
create or your tensorflow models that
you create are essentially protocol
buffer format
protocol buffers are essentially very
similar to the flat buffer format that
google has created
the major difference is flat buffers do
not need a parsing or an unpacking step
to a secondary representation before you
can access the data
and the code essentially is also larger
in case of protocol buffers
it is here while using tflight we make
use of flat buffer format and not
protocol buffer format
so now let's move forward
so far we've looked at various aspects
of edge computing we've looked at how
deploying models on edge devices is
better as compared to deploying it on
cloud
we've also looked at what tensorflow
lite is and what all it can support at
this point of time
now is where things would get
interesting wherein i'll show you
through code how tf lite can actually
compress your model size without
compromising on the accuracy piece so
now let's go forward and witness the
magic of tf light
now that we've understood the basics of
tensorflow lite and edge computing
let me show you the power of tensorflow
lite using python
so for this example i am using google
collab
for those of you who don't know google
collab is an online environment wherein
you can write python code you can create
machine learning and deep learning
models
you can also make use of deep learning
models that google gives you access to
for good amount of time
so this is the interface that i'll be
using i'll be attaching the link to the
github repository in the description
section of the video feel free to access
the code from there
also inside the github repository i'll
also give you a link that can open a
google collab notebook directly
with all the ground work done let me now
go forward and show you the magic of
tensorflow lite
so the process that i'll follow in this
particular tutorial is i'll create a
deep learning model using tensorflow
keras i will scale it down to a tf light
equivalent model
once that is accomplished i'll show you
the size difference between the original
model as well as the compressed model
i'll show you techniques how you can
keep compressing the model even further
without having to compromise on the
accuracy piece
with that let me create an instance on
google collab by pressing connect
so currently google is allocating some
space for my computations
if you're planning to replicate the
entire thing that i show in today's
video in your local machine then you
will require some set of installations
as well
given that i am working with google
collab all the dependencies that i
require for this example are already met
so now let me go through the different
things that i'll require for this entire
tutorial
first things first i'll require the os
module to essentially read my files
next up i'll import numpy as np i'll
require this particular library for
mathematical
operations i will also require h5 py
library
the h5 py library is a pythonic
interface to the hda5 binary data format
so technically whatever models i create
in keras i'll basically save it into the
h5 format
next up i require matplotlib this is
again used for visualization
i'll require tensorflow
i'll import keras from tensorflow
these are some of the layers that i'll
require when we come to the deep
learning model creation aspect
if i want to calculate how good my model
is performing in terms of accuracy score
this is where
sklearn.matrix module will give me the
accuracy score functionality
and from the system library i'll also
require the function getsizeof
so these are some of the things that i
require in order to create a ta flight
model
so now let me go forward and run the
cell
so when i run the cell what essentially
happens is python essentially runs that
piece of code so let me now go forward
and run the cell
so i don't see any error that means all
of our imports are in place
let me go forward and show you the
tensorflow version that i'm using for
this particular tutorial
i am currently using tensorflow 2.6.0
if there are changes that creep up with
respect to the api
feel free to refer to the tensorflow
documentation
there are two functions that i've
created
the first function name is get
underscore file underscore size
essentially i am passing in the file
location
using the os library and specifically
the function get size i am able to get
the size of a particular file that i
pass in in bytes
so let me now go forward and run the
cell
in the previous function that is get
underscore file underscore size
the value return would be in bytes
so now rather than comprehending the
values of a file size in bytes
i've created a helper function called as
convert underscore bytes which
essentially takes in the input size and
bytes and converts it in either kb mb
so this is something that i've created
i've not included gbs because so this is
more of an explainer video wherein i
intend to create a smaller model or
rather a proof of concept rather than
like a huge model so that is why i've
restricted my units to kb's or mb's
so let me go forward and run the cell
now for this particular example i'll be
basically using a very famous data set
in deep learning called as fashion
amnest data set so let me unhide the
cell
so fashion amnesty data set contains
seventy thousand grayscale images which
belong to ten different categories so
categories would include t-shirt trouser
pullover dress
coat
sandal shirt sneaker bag and ankle boot
so these are the different categories
that are part of this data set
the entire activity is a supervised
learning task i'll have a set of images
and every image will have a label
associated with it and i'm trying to
train a deep learning model
so now let me go forward
so you don't have to worry about the
download piece as well if you have
installed tensorflow correctly
then essentially you just have to call
the keras dot data sets dot fashion
mnist function
save the entire data set into a variable
called as fashion underscore mnist so
that is the first step that i have done
here
once you've done that then essentially
what you have to do next is you have to
split your data set into training and
testing
the way you can achieve that is ideally
by calling a function called as load
underscore data so this is what you have
in terms of the function
once you call this function from fashion
underscore mnist the variable that you
just created you would be able to split
your data into training images
training labels
test images and test labels so that's
how simple it is
so let me go forward and run the
cell so we have downloaded the data
files we've splitted our data into
training and testing
i've also created a variable a list
variable called as class underscore
names which contains all the names of
the classes that are part of this entire
activity so let me go forward and run
the cell
so if you recollect we had 70 000
samples in our data set
we've already split that entire data set
into training and testing so let me go
forward and show you how many images are
part of the training data set
so let me run the cell
so the shape of my training data set is
60 000
comma 28 comma 28
so i have 60 000 images
each image has a size of 28 cross 28 so
28 rows 28 columns represent each image
and i have 60 000 such images
given this is a supervised learning task
i would also require sixty thousand
labels so let me check if the total
number of labels in my training data set
are sixty thousand so let me run the
cell
so as you can clearly see i have sixty
thousand labels as well
now given that i have already mentioned
that there are 10 unique classes let me
verify that as well
so as you can clearly see i have class
numbers ranging from 0 to 9 and the
mapping is what i've created here which
is contained in the variable class
underscore names
let's now go forward and explore the
testing data set as well
so let me quickly unhide this
let me show you the total number of
images in the testing data set
so that come out to be 10 000 60 000 for
training 10 000 for testing each image
is again of the size 28 cross 28
similarly if i look at test underscore
labels i'll have 10 000 samples
what i intend to show you next is i want
to show you a sample image so let me
show that to you
so this is a sample image that is part
of this data set
this is clearly an ankle boot
the size of the image is 28 cross 28 so
28 rows 28 columns is what you see here
before we go forward and train a neural
network a good practice is to scale the
intensity values of the images which
range between 0 to 255
to 0 to 1. so that is what i have done
in this piece of code so let me run this
so now my train images will have values
ranging from 0 to 1 and not 0 to 255.
so far we have downloaded the data set
we have split our data set into training
and testing
and we have done some sort of
preprocessing as well
now is the time wherein we'll create a
simple neural network that can classify
the entire images into one of the 10
categories that are there
so in this piece of code i am calling
the sequential class from the keras
library
i am passing in the first layer as a
flattened layer
now if you recollect the images where 28
cross 28 if i have to pass it through a
layer then i have to basically flatten
it first
i am not creating a convolutional neural
network given that the data set is
fairly simple i will stick to a normal
deep neural network
so the first layer that i add is a
flattened layer wherein i pass the input
shape which is 28 comma 28
the second layer is the dense layer and
the activation supplied to this dense
layer is relu
the final layer is again a dense layer
given that i have 10 different classes
to classify between so that is what i
have here so let me quickly create an
instance of the model so let me run this
before we go forward and compile the
model i'll show you the structure of the
model as well so i'll say model dot
summary
so this essentially is the model summary
so for the given architecture we have
close to 100k trainable parameters
now the next step is to compile the
model
i am passing in the optimizer i am
passing in the sparse categorical cross
entropy loss
given that our classes are mutually
exclusive
i'm using the sparse categorical cross
entropy loss as compared to the normal
categorical cross entropy loss
and the matrix that i'm chasing for is
accuracy so i want to create a model
that is fairly accurate
so let me now go forward and run the
cell
so i have created an instance of the
model i have also compiled the model now
is the time wherein i will pass in the
training images as well as the training
labels to train the entire trainable
parameters
so let me now call the model.fit
function wherein i'll be passing in the
train images train labels and i'll kind
of run the entire exercise for 10 epochs
so let me run the cell
so with every epoch you can see that the
accuracy is increasing
so we have successfully trained our
model and we have reached a training
accuracy score of around 91 percent
which is something that's reasonably
good given that i've trained the model
for only 10 epochs
so let's go forward
remember one thing the objective of the
video is not to obtain the most accurate
classifier at this point of time but to
show you the power of tf light so that
is why i've kind of stopped at 10 epochs
now the next thing that i do is i create
a variable called as keras underscore
model underscore name
this is something that will be used as
reference or this will be the baseline
model performance that i'll evaluate
later on with the tflight models as well
so the name of this particular variable
is tf underscore model underscore
fashion underscore mnist dot h5 so let
me quickly run the cell
now let me go forward and call the model
dot save function and pass in the file
name that i just created so let me run
the cell
so as soon as you run the cell you would
have a file that would be created in
your google collab session or in your
local directory which is essentially
your saved model file so let me show
that as well
so this is our saved model file that has
been created
so let me quickly unite the cell again
now i'll go forward and i'll show you
the size of this particular file that
we've created
so let me call the two functions that i
have created that is convert underscore
bytes
and get underscore file underscore size
i pass in the same file name and i want
the file size to be in mb so let me run
the cell
so currently i have a model
that occupies 1.2 mb
so i'll go forward and i'll create a
variable called as keras underscore
model underscore size and save the byte
equivalent size into this particular
variable
so let me run the cell
we know for a fact that the model is
performing really well on the training
data set
but an essential litmus test is to check
how well the model is performing on
unseen data that is my testing data set
so let me go forward and evaluate how
good our model performance is on the
testing data set
so i call the function model dot
evaluate i pass in the test images test
labels
and i save the results into two
variables called as test underscore loss
and test underscore accuracy so let me
quickly run the cell
so as you can clearly see the loss is at
a very small value which is around 0.37
and i've reached a testing accuracy
score of around 88 percent
so we've completed the first part
now it's time to move on to the next
part that is creating a tf light
equivalent of the same model so let's go
forward
so i start the activity by creating a
variable called as tf underscore light
underscore model underscore file
underscore name and i pass in an
equivalent name to this particular ta
flight model which in our case currently
is tf underscore lite underscore model
dot ta flight so let me quickly run the
cell
now the process of converting a
tensorflow model or a keras model into a
ta flight model
essentially requires just a couple of
steps so this is what i'll highlight
right now
so the first step is to call pf dot
light dot ta flight converter
dot from keras underscore model
i pass in the model that i created
so if you remember the name of the model
variable was essentially model so that
is what i am passing in here in the
first line
once i have created an instance of the
ta flight converter from kira's model i
save the entire piece into a variable
called as tf underscore light underscore
converter
and finally what i do next is i call the
convert function once the conversion
happens i want the result to be saved
into a variable called as ta flight
underscore model so let me quickly run
the cell
so if you look at the output it says
that assets are written into a
particular temporary file
so from that temporary file i basically
have to retrieve the model weights
and save it into a tf lite equivalent
file so that is what i have done using
this piece of code
i have created the first variable which
is tf lite underscore model underscore
name and i'm passing in the initial name
that i've created in the first line of
this particular section
i open the file name
with write access and i write this
particular temporary file into this file
that i've created so that's how simple
it is so let me quickly run this
so there is a particular output that is
displayed this tells me the total number
of bytes that have been written to this
particular file
now let me go forward and show you the
exact size of this tf light model in
kilobytes so let me run this
so the overall file size is close to 400
kilobytes
so we started off with a model which was
occupying around 1.2 mb
and after just running a couple of lines
of code we have brought down the file
size to around 400 kb
now let me go forward and save this file
size into a variable called as tf lite
underscore file underscore size
this is something that will make a lot
of sense once we go forward so let me
quickly run the cell
now we've already converted a model from
keras to tf light but one thing that
we've not validated currently is how
good the model is in terms of
performance
is it actually good on unseen data or
has it dropped in terms of the accuracy
score
so that is what i want to check next
that after compressing the model using
tf lite are we losing out on accuracy or
not
so in this section i'll go over how you
can validate the results in terms of how
good your tflight model is performing so
now let me quickly unhide the cell
now don't get scared by looking at this
piece of code i'll help you understand
what i'm trying to achieve here
now loading a model a tensorflow or a
keras model into a tensorflow session is
fairly easy
but here what we have done is we've kind
of created a ta flight model
if you go back to the discussion that we
had
pflight models are essentially flat
buffer format files and not your normal
usual protocol buffer files
so in order for us to actually make an
inference out of pflight files on our
tensorflow or python session we require
something called as an interpreter
so it is here that we will be basically
making use of tensorflow's interpreter
to load the tflight file and then make
inferences or
predictions so let me now take you
through each and every line of code
so in the first line i create an
instance of the interpreter class
i pass in the ta flight model name that
we've just created so
if you look at this particular section
you would also have a ta flight file
this is what i'm passing in here
now once we've created the interpreter
object
the interpreter object saves details
about the model
it will have details about the input
that it expects
the value the type of values it expects
and in terms of the output it will tell
you what the shape of the output should
be
in terms of the output it will tell you
the output shape as well as the output d
type that is the output values it will
predict what are the values and what are
the type of values so all of that is
what this particular interpreter will
actually have details about
the details it is fetching is again from
the interpreter object that we created
and we passed in the tf flight file so
all of the details would be captured in
this particular ta flight file which is
what is read by this interpreter object
and that is what we are trying to
accumulate from input underscore details
and output underscore details
once we have the input and output
details i also am interested in the
shape of the input that is expected
and the type of inputs or the variable
nature of the inputs that are there so
let me quickly run this cell to make
more sense
so if you look closely
the input shape is
128.28
the input type that it expects is numpy
float32
the output shape is 1 comma 10 that is 1
so it basically has one row and 10
columns
and the output type is again numpy
float32
so this is essentially what the tf lite
file contains
now if you look at this particular one
this denotes that the tf light is
expecting one input at a time
now i want to check how good it is
performing for 10 000 inputs
that is where i'll have to reshape the
input shape to a particular value which
is what i'll be achieving in this piece
of code
just to reiterate again
the input shape is
128.28
so ideally i have to pass in just one
image sample
and essentially i would get a
corresponding output for it
but essentially in my use case i want to
validate how good the tflight model is
performing for the testing data set that
i have which essentially contains 10 000
images
so if this idea is clear to you let's go
forward
so now i want to validate how good my
pflight model is performing on my
testing data set
so i call the resize underscore tensor
underscore input function
i pass in the details that i want to
resize this particular index value and i
pass in how i have to resize it so
currently i have 10 000 samples so that
is what i have entered here that is 10
000 comma 28 comma 28
similar resize operation is what i'm
doing at the output side so
you can see here 10 000 comma 10
from the initial 1 comma 10. so that is
what i have done here
now once the resize operation has
happened i want to call the allocate
tensors to actually change the entire
structure of the interpreter this is
what it's read using the ta flight file
and now when i print the input details
and output details
i should be able to see that the entire
pflight input output values have changed
so let me quickly run this piece of code
so as you can clearly see the input
shape has changed from 128.28
to 102828
so this essentially will help me to
validate how good my tflight model is
performing
the other thing that i want to highlight
right now is
test underscore images dot d type
is float 64.
so if you look at the input shape that
the model expects is numpy dot float32
so now the only other change that i have
to make in order to validate my pflight
model is i have to create a new array
called as test underscore images
underscore numpy
pass in the original array
and change the d type
i can do it in the same array as well
but i am essentially choosing to create
two different arrays so let me quickly
run the cell
so now if i show you the d type of test
underscore images.numpy
it will be numpyfloat32
now that we have the entire interpreter
object set up correctly for our set of
inputs that is the testing data set
all i have to do right now is firstly
call the set underscore tensor function
pass in the test underscore images
underscore numpy array that i just
created
call the invoke function
what the invoke function would
essentially do is pass in the inputs get
the output and once you have the output
ready you call the get underscore tensor
function which will kind of have the
output ready for you
and save it into a variable called as tf
tflight underscore model underscore
predictions so let me quickly run the
cell
now the output that you see here which
is prediction results shape is 10 000
rows and 10 columns
so every column would essentially
contain a probability score so what i
have to do next is i have to pick out
the value or the index between 0 to 9
that has the maximum probability which
is what i've done using this function
called as np dot argmax
so this will help me get numbers
directly that is 0 to 9 rather than
having 10 different columns with
probability scores
now let me calculate the accuracy score
and let me print it out for you
so the testing accuracy of the tflight
model is exactly the same that you see
when you compare it with your normal
keras model
now how much of space have we saved in
this entire process well let me
calculate a ratio between tf light file
size and keras model file size
so overall
the ta flight model occupies close to 32
percent of the overall file size that my
normal keras model occupies
but the uniqueness is that i'm not
losing out on any accuracy so this is
the power of ta flight
i've been able to compress my entire
model from 1.2 mb to around 400 kb
and i haven't yet compromised a bit on
the accuracy piece as well
isn't this amazing
well if you think the story is ended
here
hang on for a second there is more to go
so far what we have done is i have taken
a tensorflow model and without any
optimization i have basically converted
that into an equivalent ta flight model
now i'll show you how you can compress
your model even further
without losing out on accuracy as such
so now let me introduce you to a new
concept called as quantization
so what exactly is this term that i've
just mentioned that is quantization
so for a given weight value that can be
represented in float 32 or float 64
format
wouldn't it be great if we can bring
down the size of those particular values
and see very little change in accuracy
well this essentially is the concept of
quantization
i am reducing the total number of bits
for every weight value so that the
overall size of the entire array reduces
just to be more clear if i have a neural
network something like this
where this particular weight value is
5.31345
this particular weight value is 3.8958
and you have the other weight values as
well
what if i can change these
representations that occupy so many bits
to something like this
there will be a small hit in the
accuracy but overall i'll be able to
compress my model even further
how when whatever questions you have in
mind
just wait for some time
if this entire idea is clear to you let
us go back to the coding section and
i'll show you how you can compress your
tflight model even further
so by default in the previous example
wherein we took a keras model and we
converted that to a ta flight model
every weight value is essentially float
32 format
wouldn't it be great if i compress it
from float 32 to float 16.
well this is the activity that i'll be
performing next
so i create a variable with the name tf
underscore light underscore model
underscore float underscore 16
underscore file underscore name
and i basically give it a tf light name
which essentially represents that the
entire weights inside it would be fluid
16 so that is what i have here
so let me quickly run the cell
if you look at the previous section in
terms of how we created a tflight model
the first line of code is something that
is pretty much familiar to you you pass
in your keras model
you call the tflight converter dot from
keras model and you save it into a
variable
even the last piece of code is also
something that we've already looked at
what you haven't seen so far is the
optimization so when you create an
instance of the tflight converter
there is a flag called as optimizations
so you have the optimizations flag here
i set it to
tf.light.optimize.default so i want the
default optimizations to take place
and
one other change that i do here
so i'll speak more about the
optimizations in the next section so
hold on to that thought as well
now here there is one more flag called
as target underscore spec
and supported underscore types
here is where i set
every weight value from float 32 to
float 16 so that is what i am doing here
so
let me quickly run this piece of code
so now i have a tf lite model
wherein every weight value would be of
float 16 format
i follow the same process again wherein
i am fetching data from the temporary
file and saving it into a tflight model
so let me run this
i don't know if you've guessed it
already or not this essentially is the
file size and bytes for the newly
converted ta flight model so if i now
show you the size of this newly
converted tf light model
then my size has drastically reduced
from 400 kilobytes to 200 kilobytes
only thing that i changed here was i
changed the individual representation of
every weight value that's about it isn't
this amazing i'm able to save so much of
memory
just by changing few values here and
there
so i again save the file size into a
variable called as ta flight underscore
float underscore 16 underscore file
underscore size so let me run this
now if i compare it to the original
keras model
this particular model occupies 16 of the
size that the original model occupied
and if i compare it to the previously
created version
then i can see almost a 50 percent
compression that i am able to achieve by
changing the weights from float 32 to
float 16.
so this is the power of optimizations in
tf light
if you think this is it wait for the
next section wherein i compress the
model even further
i am not showing you the accuracy piece
right now you might be wondering why
zanthi showing us the accuracy has
accuracy taken a toss well the answer is
no i'll show you the accuracy of an even
compressed model so that will give you a
fair sense in terms of
how much compression is changing the
overall accuracy values as well okay
so now we have reached the final section
wherein i'll compress the model even
further okay
so here i've created a variable called
as tf underscore light underscore size
underscore quant underscore model
underscore file underscore name
and here i want to save a dflight file
with this particular name so i'll
quickly run the cell
in the previous example i changed every
weight value from floor 32 to float 16
rather than you deciding what is good
for your model
i would rather let tf light decide that
for me so
if you've been following along so far
then this piece of code is something
that we've already covered
this piece of code is also something
that we've already covered
this is something that is unique
so here i set the optimizations flag
and here i just mentioned optimize for
size there are different values that you
can kind of go through in the
documentation
so based on your needs you can kind of
optimize for size and the other
optimization that are also available for
ta flight so
i'm not specifying what type of data
type i want i just want the most
optimized version
where in the size that is occupied by
this particular ta flight model is the
most compressed version okay
so i'll quickly run the cell
so i catch hold of the file that is
saved into a temporary variable i save
it into this particular variable that i
created
and if you've guessed by now
this is the new file size in bytes
if i go to the kilobyte section
then my file occupies around 100 kb
so if you remember we started from
1.4 mb
and we've brought down the file size of
a deep neural network 200 kilobytes
isn't this amazing
just to give you some numbers again
if i compare
this particular file size with my
original file size
then my current file is almost eight
percent the size of my original file
that is my keras model that i created
if i compare it to the previous model as
well
i am basically able to achieve 50
compression
all because of optimizing for size
this essentially is the power of tf
light
now i am really happy with the
compression
i have a 1.4 mb file that i have
compressed down to around 100 kb
but is the accuracy still the same
well we'll again follow the same process
wherein i'll load the newly quantized
model
into the interpreter object
i'll get details of those objects and
i'll again reshape the values
and pass up testing data set entirely
through the interpreter object so
i'll quickly run the cell
so as you can clearly see 128 28 is the
interpreter object's input values that
it expects
i have the output as one comma 10.
the input and output values that are
expected are numpy float32 so that is
all good as well
coming to the final section
i follow the same process again no
change in the process i have a testing
data set of 10 000 images which is what
i pass in here
i allocate tensors i get the details and
i'll show the details to you as well so
let me quickly run this
ten thousand twenty eight twenty eight
one twenty eight twenty eight so we've
resized the tensor input values that we
are expecting to validate our testing
data set
you essentially don't need the step
again but i've kind of copied it from
the initial part so i'm running it again
i pass in the values again
now i calculate the accuracy score
now is the litmus test for this highly
compressed ta flight model so let me
quickly run the cell
so the accuracy of a ta flight model
that occupies almost eight percent of
the size of the original keras model
is equivalent to the original keras
model if i go up
i am recording this video in one go so
if i go up
where did this value go
here the value was
87.66 percent
here it is at
87.59 percent
so this is what you can achieve using ta
flight
i started off with a very simple neural
network
the entire model occupied around 1.2 mb
you might also argue that 1.2 mb is kind
of small
but the problem statement was fairly
simple if you have like a really complex
example wherein you have to classify
images into thousand or ten thousand
the model size would eventually increase
so the objective then becomes can we
compress the model size and the answer
is yes tf light will help you compress
the model size
without having to compromise any bit on
the accuracy front
if you've reached this point then i'm
assuming you've seen the entire video or
if randomly reached at this point
whichever way you've reached this point
i hope you enjoyed today's video i keep
creating such amazing videos on data
science machine learning and python so
feel free to check out my channel in the
description section of the video as well
thank you so much for watching this
video